So let's start in our main.js we'll get rid
of this console log here
And we can start off by just crying this
hero healthAnd we'll do hero Health equals
100.
And let's make sure we know these are
different we can putOur section tag up here
and we'll say hero.
And then let's go ahead and do the same
thing here and I'll say sectionVillain. No
say let villain help.
Equal 100 for now as well
Let's just go ahead and make this equal 150
we'll give it some some variance to make it
We'll give some very interest make the the
villain a little bit tougher than we areGive
him a chance.
So let's start by just creating a function
That can reduce the villain's health so
we'll actually trade a function we'll just
call this function attack for now
Cuz this will be that middle button in the
screen that we had
So when I clicked this I want to essentially
first have the
hero Health go down by 5:00 so let's first
console logHero Health here.
And it should be 100 at firstNext let's
actually decrease that health.
So we'll decrease the total hero Health
hereAnd we can do that simply by just saying
hero health.
And then let's do minus equals 5
And let's actually check with the hero
health isWe'll say hero Health after damage.
And let's save thatLet's go to our Dom.
And in here we can actually invoke that
attack function
And we see we get hero Health 100 and hero
Health after damage went down in 95
And we can do it again and we start with 95
so you can see we still have that 95 so it
stays it holds that scope for that hero
Health every time I do this so should go
from 90 to 85Perfect.
Now that we know this bun is operating let's
do the same thing for villain Health as well
Why is it returning undefined I'm not even
returning anythingSay return no.
So it's creating another section
here we'll say villain
So let's do the same thing we can say
console.log
About to attackVillain.
And we'll grab that bill and help as well
And we'll do minus equals 10
And we'll just say attacked the villain here
as well and let's we should have the same
result
So in our Dom let's go ahead and initialize
that attackSo we get.
So we get our hero Health hero Health after
damage about to attack villain attacked
And the cool thing is we can keep doing this
for as long as we want but we have to keep
initializing that
So let's make it a little bit easier on
ourselves and let's assign that function to
this button here
And to do that we have our function attack
right hereNow we need to implement this in
our on our button.
And we're going to do that by targeting this
button right hereAnd let's assign this
property of onclick.
And we're actually just going to go Target
that attack function the name of it
So it needs to be exactly the same as thisSo
if you.
Are unsure about spelling you can actually
come here and just copy itAnd then paste it
in here and let's save that and go back to
our web application.
So from here I should be able to click
attack now and we should get those console
logs to pop up
Perfect
We have now added some functionality to our
web application and we can see it working
every time I click it
And we get these outputs from that function
we create